Trascrizione: Laura Pasquale
Revisore: Stefania Recchia
Allora, io quando sono stata invitata
a parlare in questo evento
ho letto "TED Woman" e quindi ho immediatamente
scritto due pagine piene di
argomenti riguardanti la mia,
il mio stato di donna e il mio lavoro.
Ovviamente c'era una quantità di rabbia e
di energia, positiva e negativa, devo dire.
Però comunque era troppo, era troppo forte,
era troppo forte e non era obbiettivo
e in più non aveva niente a
che vedere con l'innovazione.
Quindi ho preso, ho buttato via i quasi due fogli
e ho riscritto quello che vi racconterò oggi.
Io mi occupo appunto di innovazione,
perché sono una designer.
Però non è detto che questa
innovazione sia automatica,
cioè non è che uno studia design
e in automatico lavora in un gruppo innovativo.
Quello di cui vorrei parlare oggi è proprio
l'innovazione in tutti i lavori,
cioè questo tipo di energia
e di capacità innovativa, quindi la creatività,
è dentro tutti i gruppi di lavoro, in qualsiasi lavoro.
E quindi vorrei parlare di come è possibile
creare dei gruppi di lavoro che siano più creativi.
Comunque, di quei due fogli che ho buttato via,
volevo introdurre con una gaffe
che ho fatto recentemente
durante il Salone del Mobile.
Ero andata a intervistare Karim Rashid,
che è un famoso designer internazionale
e ero evidentemente incinta di 6 mesi
e sapevo che lui aveva appena avuto una bambina
e quindi, così, per rompere il ghiaccio, ho detto:
"Ah, Karim, ho saputo che hai appena
avuto una bambina. Che bello.
Anch'io sto per avere una bambina."
Lui: "Ah, si, bene."
E poi ho detto: "Mah, però insomma,
trovo veramente vergognoso. Come
hai fatto con i vestitini della bambina?
Perché tutte le marche vendono solo
e danno solo il rosa per le bambine."
Evidentemente nessuno ride, quindi
nessuno conosce Karim Rashid.
Questo è Karim Rashid.
[Risate]
Era vestito esattamente così, cioè davanti a me
avevo un uomo completamente in rosa.
Non so perché è uscito...
quindi la gaffe l'ho capita dopo,
dopo pochi minuti. E lui forse
non l'ha neanche capita,
comunque è stato elegante, ha detto:
"No, io ho comprato tutto su internet,
non vado nei negozi".
E comunque sia, evidentemente
riflettendo su questa gaffe,
il rosa per lui è un'opportunità per essere diverso,
per noi è una condanna.
Diciamo, questa è la riflessione che mi è venuta.
Però perché questo è importante nella mia vita?
Probabilmente è importante perché io da piccola
ho avuto la fortuna di vivere negli Stati Uniti
e poi ci siamo trasferiti a Napoli.
Ovviamente c'è uno shock culturale evidente
[Risate]
però lo shock, quello che mi ricordo di più...
ce ne sono tante di cose che mi sono accadute,
ma una delle cose principali che io
ho scoperto, a Napoli, sulla mia pelle,
è che le donne non giocano a calcio.
Cioè, è vietato.
Io adoravo giocare a calcio negli Stati Uniti.
Arrivata a Napoli, divieto assoluto.
Durante le ricreazioni e durante l'educazione fisica
ovviamente le donne giocano a pallavolo,
gli uomini giocano a calcio,
poi c'era questo giocare a basket,
non era ben definito,
quindi a volte si giocava a basket,
e si poteva giocare,
però il calcio era vietato.
E quindi forse questo, questo lato
diciamo anglosassone
mi è rimasto dentro, questo chip,
e si è unito, si è mescolato a quello mediterraneo,
perché io sono napoletana di origine.
E quindi quello anglosassone è quello che dice
sul lavoro che tutti, che bisogna come...
in un gruppo di lavoro,
bisogna tirar fuori tutti quegli elementi
che anche non sono sul curriculum, cioè
tutte le forze che abbiamo, tutte le capacità,
anche creative, che applichiamo in tutt'altri settori,
e magari sul lavoro siamo per niente creativi.
Ecco, se si riesce, come io dirigo un
gruppo di donne in questo momento,
e se si riesce a tirar fuori da tutte queste persone
che lavorano per noi e con noi, in realtà,
se si parla in anglosassone,
se si riesce a tirar fuori quegli
elementi, si può essere creativi.
La parte invece mediterranea
è quella della passione,
ovviamente, e quella della, diciamo
del divertirsi anche con gli imprevisti.
Questi due elementi, io mi sono resa conto appunto
pensando al mio lavoro, a quello che,
che cosa ho apportato di innovativo,
sicuramente ho lavorato sul prodotto
che noi abbiamo realizzato, ho portato innovazione.
Ma quello, mi sono accorta che in questi anni
io ho diretto 2 gruppi, in particolare
erano solo gruppi di donne,
e mi sono accorta che l'energia
maggiore che io ho speso
era nel rendere queste persone felici.
E me ne sono accorta scrivendo il testo per oggi.
Cioè, io spendo tantissima energia per fare in modo
che le persone che lavorano con me siano felici
e che io stessa sia felice.
Ovviamente questa parola,
la felicità, la serenità sul lavoro,
son tutte cose intangibili, difficili da definire.
E quindi ho cercato per oggi di almeno portare
3 elementi che io ritengo importanti.
Il primo elemento è quello del tempo, cioè
noi viviamo in una società, credo
tutti voi lo vivete anche voi,
in una società in cui siamo privati del tempo,
del vero valore del tempo.
Mi ricordo quando vivevamo negli Stati Uniti
gli auguri arrivavano attraverso il telegramma.
Gli auguri di Natale, al compleanno,
e ci si riuniva tutti e poi c'era il papà o mamma
che aprivano il telegramma: "Auguri. Nonna".
Basta, finito lì.
Però era emozionante, perché questo telegramma
il telegramma era il mezzo
più veloce per fare arrivare
gli auguri dall'altra parte del mondo.
E quindi il telegramma dava proprio l'idea
del vero valore della distanza,
ma anche del vero valore del tempo.
Oggi invece, appunto, dobbiamo lavorare di sabato,
di domenica, di notte, durante le vacanze, cellulari,
rispondiamo soltanto a mail,
praticamente siamo schiavi
delle mail, degli SMS, quindi
rispondere alle mail velocemente,
agli SMS ancora più velocemente,
insomma, tutto veloce
e si perde il valore del tempo proprio per riflettere,
per perdersi in particolare,
per perdersi e per sbagliare.
Infatti, il secondo elemento
di cui voglio parlare è l'errore.
Viviamo, di nuovo, in una società in cui se sbagliamo
vuol dire che abbiamo fallito.
Invece nell'ambito dell'innovazione
l'errore è fondamentale.
È una delle risorse più importanti.
L'essere capace di sbagliare, per poi imparare
da quell'errore e trasformarlo in un'innovazione,
è uno degli ingredienti che ha portato
proprio a delle innovazioni,
ed è innovazioni che poi
tra l'altro noi conosciamo,
per esempio la penicillina:
uno scienziato è andato in vacanza,
ha lasciato in disordine il suo laboratorio,
si è creata della muffa,
quella muffa è l'antibiotico.
Piuttosto che i post-it: un altro
personaggio ricercatore,
cerca di fare la colla più potente del mondo,
crea la colla più inutile del mondo, che però
si trasforma in una cosa utile con i post-it.
Piuttosto che un altro signore che,
appunto, va in vacanza
o fa delle belle camminate nei boschi,
si attaccano questi inutili fiori sul pullover,
lui è uno scienziato, analizza
l'attacco del fiore e crea il velcro.
Quindi, ecco, sono tutti casi interessanti,
ma nell'ambito del design, giusto
per portare appunto il mio mondo qui,
invece ci sono i casi
per esempio di un imprenditore
che è andato in vacanza a Londra,
ha visto il famoso,
la paperella, quella famosa
fatta di gomma piuma,
pensa: "Ah cavolo, quella tecnologia
applicata però ai mobili,
potrebbe essere interessante",
e nasce il divano,
il divano che noi conosciamo,
quello fatto di gomma piuma,
nasce in Italia, un'innovazione italiana.
Piuttosto che quattro amici, uno che lavora
per una famosa azienda italiana
delle gomme, diciamo,
un altro che appunto è un designer,
un altro ancora che è uno scienziato
nell'ambito delle plastiche,
che devono andare sciare,
perché vanno a sciare insieme,
hanno bisogno di un portasci,
perché non esiste ancora
e creano appunto il primo portasci.
Questo poi diventa il primo prodotto
di una delle più importanti
aziende di mobili in plastica.
C'era una sedia prima di quella stessa azienda.
Un altro esempio è questo,
che voi probabilmente conoscete.
La storia di questo oggetto è bellissima.
Praticamente Philippe Starck
pare che mangiasse serenamente
in un ristorante nel Sud d'Italia e così, spremendo,
stava mangiando dei moscardini, decide di spremere
la testa del moscardino su un limone
e da lì l'idea dello spremiagrumi.
Infatti, arriva in azienda direttamente il disegno
sulla tovaglietta dove stava mangiando.
Quindi, l'errore è un elemento assolutamente fondamentale per innovare.
Dobbiamo però avere il coraggio di errare.
Negli Stati Uniti, appunto, si usa molto
nel mondo del design in realtà,
si usa molto il "fail early to succeed sooner",
quindi "sbaglia presto per
avere successo il prima possibile".
Quindi l'errore fa parte proprio anche della costruzione dei prototipi nel mondo del design.
Più prototipi facciamo, per realizzare una sedia,
e per fare una buona sedia non basta dire
"ah, voglio fare la sedia più bella del mondo",
ma ci vogliono almeno 2 anni, 2 anni
di sperimentazioni sui materiali,
4 o 5 prototipi e tante teste,
quindi le squadre costituite da persone
che provengono da tante conoscenze diverse.
Quindi l'innovazione nonè legata
a una singola persona.
Viviamo in un mondo in cui
la squadra multidisciplinare
è il gruppo più innovatore del mondo.
Ma lo è sempre stato. Non è una novità.
Si attribuisce, per comodità, l'innovazione
a una singola persona,
ma in realtà è sempre frutto di una squadra,
la squadra che è composta da
diverse persone nell'azienda
e non soltanto dall'imprenditore
e da un designer esterno.
Il terzo elemento di cui invece volevo parlare
è proprio la curiosità.
Achille Castiglioni, che è
un famoso designer italiano,
dice che un buon designer
dev'essere curioso del mondo.
E questo è vero. Spesso nel mondo del design
si dice che bisogna essere curiosi come bambini,
però forse non è proprio esattamente così,
essere bambini sempre.
Quello che mi piace è riflettere su tre parole:
guardare, osservare e vedere.
Cioè, se guardiamo qualcosa ne vediamo i confini,
vediamo i colori, vediamo
più o meno gli aspetti estetici.
Se la osserviamo la guardiamo un po' più da vicino,
riusciamo a capire un po' meglio
come si relaziona col mondo e come funziona.
Ma se la vediamo vuol dire che noi capiamo
realmente il perché quella cosa esiste.
Ecco, noi al giorno d'oggi
– per quello che mi riguarda,
per quello che riguarda il mio lavoro –
capisco che siamo fermi sul guardare.
Cioè noi guardiamo il mondo, ma
ci manca l'osservare e il vedere.
Perché appunto ci manca il tempo
e ci manca la possibilità di errare.
Purtroppo quest'anno è stato il primo
anno in università dove insegno
– insegno a 90 studenti "design thinking" –
ed è stato il primo anno che abbiamo
avuto una grave assenza,
cioè abbiamo avuto assenza di quote azzurre.
Per entrare nel nostro corso
bisogna avere la media alta
e evidentemente le donne
arrivano ad avere la media alta.
Ma la mancanza di quote azzurre
è una mancanza gravissima.
Cioè, un buon gruppo di innovatori deve avere una,
diciamo un'unione, non soltanto di diverse discipline,
ma anche proprio dei sessi, perché
l'apporto dei due sessi è diverso.
Infatti nel nostro corso noi, diciamo,
mescoliamo i gruppi,
chiediamo di formare dei gruppi di 4 o 5
persone e ci sono delle regole.
Dovete, appunto mescolare le culture,
dovete mescolare le discipline
e sono bravissimi, si mescolano.
E poi una delle regole è "divieto assoluto
di creare gruppi di solo donne o di solo uomini",
perché dalla nostra esperienza,
almeno nella didattica,
il gruppo di solo donne fa un progetto perfetto,
ma per i bambini, come se fossimo
destinate a far solo quello.
E il gruppo di solo uomini
prende un po' due strade.
Uno, o crea dei mostri tecnologici
senza nessun'umanità,
oppure l'altro, che forse è peggio,
il secondo è peggio,
che è quello che si perdono in discorsi filosofici
e non riescono mai a concretizzare.
[Risate]
Quindi questo...
Ecco, io in questi ultimi anni, dico purtroppo
perché appunto ho sentito una grande
mancanza delle quote azzurre,
perché ho diretto in due posti diversi
gruppi di solo donne.
Lavoriamo ovviamente bene, però la
mancanza delle quote azzurre si sente.
Credo che quello che a me interessava,
diciamo, comunicare oggi
è che ormai per fortuna noi non viviamo più
nel mondo del fordismo, del taylorismo,
dove bisogna timbrare il cartellino,
dove bisogna essere presenti.
La tecnologia è fantastica, perché mi permette
oggi che, appunto, ho una bambina,
di non mandare più un telegramma ai miei fratelli
che vivono a New York e a Barcellona,
ma di parlargli via Skype.
Bellissimo, nella mia vita privata.
Ma nella mia vita lavorativa, questa
tecnologia mi sta ammazzando.
Quindi io credo che, e spero,
io non ci sono ancora riuscita,
ma parlandone qui mi fa capire quanto
sia importante anche per la mia vita,
che sia importante trovare dei metodi di lavoro
che vadano oltre la tecnologia che,
diciamo, per la quale noi siamo diventati schiavi.
Secondo me la tecnologia dev'essere
schiava lei della nostra umanità,
e spero che nei prossimi anni ci riusciremo.
Grazie.
[Applausi]